a pilot flying over the Napa and Sonoma
wildfires had this view smoke is
breaking through the clouds more than
5,000 feet up in the air cAL FIRE scizor
deputy director Daniel Berlant is with
us from Sacramento good morning good
morning can you tell us where you are in
fighting this fire because you have
obviously conditions with wind and
dryness that that accelerate its spread
well the good news was the wind
overnight did die down compared to what
we saw last week that's really given us
an opportunity to take a stand against
many of these fires now what we were
experiencing just 24 hours ago is a very
different story but there's still a lot
of work ahead of us as dry conditions
and warm temperatures continue to have a
strong hold here on California I know
you've got more than 2,000 firefighters
on the ground what's the biggest
challenge it's really been the
unpredictable winds it's those winds
that fan these flames from rural areas
right into the homes burning everything
in its path our latest estimates still
show that 1,500 homes and other
commercial buildings were destroyed by
these fires can you give us a sense of
the scale of the destruction that you've
seen thus far you know the destruction
is widespread complete subdivisions that
communities destroyed burned down to the
ground it was all our firefighters could
do that night of the fire just to get
people evacuated there were countless
rescues trying to get residents out of
there trapped homes and that really took
the priority protecting life and
property is always gonna be the priority
well we wish you all the best Daniel
Berlant thank you so much with cAL FIRE